اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
استمرار وتوافد القاده العرب الى جده
والرئاسه السوريه تعلن وصول الاسد في وقت
لاحق اليوم
عرض سوريا
عضو كامل العضويه له كل ابو الغيط يؤكد
للعربيه عوده سوريا كعضو كامل الحقوق في
جامعه الدول باجماع عربي
يؤكد اعتزامه نشره وثائق تكشف تفاصيل
جديده في حادثه اغتيال الرئيس كندي حال
انتخابه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اعلنت الرئاسه السوريه ان الرئيس
بشار الاسد يتجه اليوم الى جده للمشاركه
في القمه العربيه وقد وصل الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس الى مطار جده هذا
اليوم كان الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي اول الواصلين الى جده للمشاركه في
القمه العربيه في دورتها 32 وينتظر
استمرار توافد قاده الدول العربيه باعا
الى جده التي ستشهد لقاءات جانبيه تجمع
عددا من قاده وزعماء الدول العربيه على
هامش القمه العربيه جديرهم بالذكر ان
القمه التي تستضيفها السعوديه تاتي وسطى
ظروف استثنائيه تمر بها المنطقه والعالم
وتعمل من خلالها جامعه الدول العربيه
والقاده العرب على مواجهه التحديات
المشتركه وتعزيز الامن والاستقرار
الاقليمي
[موسيقى]
هذا وفي مقابله مع العربيه قلم معاون وزير
الخارجيه السوري ايمن سوسان قال ان سوريا
لم تغب عن الجامعه العربيه بل ان التحديات
والظروف هي من فرضت عليها الغياب سوريا لم
تغب عن الجامعه العربيه او عن العرب لتعود
اليهم سوريا حاره دائما وكلمات جميع من
الوفود العربيه بالامس تحدثت عن هذا
الحضور الدائم لسوريا في الوجدان العربيه
هناك ظروف
فرضت هذا الشيء ربما يكون علينا جميعا
اما العوده
لا اعتقد ان المصطلح هو صحيح المهم اليوم
نحن مع بعض هذا هو الوضع الطبيعي علينا
كعرب ان نكون مع بعض لان في ذلك الخلاص
لنا ما شهدته دولنا خلال 12 سنه الماضيه
يثبت هذا الشيء الشرور التي احاطت ببعض
الدول العربيه انعكست على الجميع وبالتالي
انعكست على الواقع العربي كان الواقع
العربي غير سار فاصبح واقعا ماسويا
طبعا عوده سوريا الى المشهد العربي اضافه
الى الاقتتال في السودان والعديد من
الملفات والقضايا تستعد القمه العربيه
الثانيه والثلاثين في جده لمناقشتها
الزميل عبد الرحمن العصيمي رصد لنا ابرز
هذه النقاط في هذا التقرير
ملفات ساخنه وتحديات عده تواجه القمه
العربيه الثانيه 32 في مدينه جده التي
تاتي في ظل ظروف امنيه معقده تمر بها
المنطقه العربيه والعالميه على حد سواء ما
ابرزوا هذه الملفات ملف الازمه السودانيه
من ابرز الملفات المطروحه على طاوله القمه
العربيه وسط توقعات بتحرك عربي واسع
لانهاء حاله الاقتتال استكمالا للدوري
السعودي القائم حاليا عمليه السلام في
اليمن واتمامها ستكون من اولويات القمه
العربيه حيث من المتوقع ان يكون هناك دعم
عربي للتوافق اليمني المنبثقي من الاتفاق
السعودي اليمني لتحقيق الاستقرار الدائم
في البلاد ايضا من ابرز ملفات المطروحه في
قمه جده عوده سوريا الى الحضن العربي
وتعزيزه اع دمجها في المشهد العربي عبر
اطلاق مبادرات وتوصيات مرتقبه في بيان
القمه الختامي الامن الغذائي هو الاخر
يعتبر من الملفات المشتركه على اجنده
القمه العربيه ما يستدعي ضروره تحقيق
السله الغذائيه الواحده التي تحقق
الاكتفاء الذاتي للعرب بحسب الخبراء الامن
المائي كذلك ياتي ضمن ابرز ملفاته قمه جدا
لاسيما في ظل النزاعات الاقليميه الراهنه
سواء مرتبطه في السودان ومصر مع اثيوبيا
او في سوريا والعراق مع تركيا ملفات اخرى
سيناقشها الزعماء العرب في قمتهم 32
الاوضاع السياسيه في ليبيا ودعم الجهود
لتحديد موعد للانتخابات بالاضافه الى
النهوض بالعمل العربي المشترك ووضع اليه
الزاميه لتطبيق ومتابعه مخرجات قرارات
القمه العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي من
مدينه جده العربيه
هذا وفي مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال
الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه احمد
ابو الغيط قال ان قرار اعاده سوريا الى
الحضن العربي لا يعني استئناف العلاقات
بين جميع الدول العربيه وسوريا لان الامر
متروك لكل دوله لتقرير ذلك وفق رؤيتها
دعونا نتابع النهارده سوريا
عضو كامل العضويه له كل الصلاحيات وكل
الحقوق وكل الواجبات على
الدوله العظم طبعا هذه العوده
لا تفرض على الدول اعضاء الجامعه نهجم
معين تجاه
الحكومه السوريه هي عاده
بتوافق من الجميع
هناك من سوف يعيد علاقات وهناك من سوف
يتحفظ في اعاده العلاقات هذا امر خاص
بزياده كل دوله لكن عضويتها كامله
واعتقد انها
سببت
غضب لدى اعداء الحكم في سوريا في العالم
الغربي اساسا
ابو الغيط اكد ان خطوه اعاده سوريا الى
جامعه الدول العربيه جاءت من خلال جهود
عربيه مشتركه من اجل وضع حل للازمه في
سوريا
عوده سوريا
عوده في سياق
ساعه عربي لتسهيل تسويه الوضع السوري
بسميه الوضع السوري زميل الاشكاليه
السوريه
والحكومه السوريه والحكم في سوريا قابل
بان تكون هذه العوده في سياق بحث في كيفيه
وبالتالي في كيفيه
وبالتالي
العرب طرحوا نفسهم
اساسا
لمساعد للحكومه السوريه
للتواصل الى بر الامان او البر الاستقرار
او
المزيد معنا من المركز الاعلامي للقمه
العربيه في جده مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن
العصيمي اهلا بك عبد الرحمن المشهد من
عندك تفضل
نعم ميسون حتى الان وصل الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس
ايضا رئيس المصري ورئيس الوزراء
اللبناني نجيب ميقاتي متوقع وصول الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد حوالي الساعه السابعه
مساء بتوقيت جده ومن ثم ايضا سيصلون
الزعماء والقاده العرب تباعا حتى صباح يوم
غد الجمعه متوقع ان تنعقد القمه يوم غد
تقريبا بعد الظهر بعد الظهر تقريبا بحضور
لافت جدا وتمثيل عالي للغايه من جميع
الوفود العربيه في الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
ميسون كان هناك اجتماعات تحضيريه عده على
مستوى وزراء الخارجي وايضا اللجان التابعه
لجامعه الدول العربيه تحضيرا لهذه القمه
الميسون ايضا ملفت انتباهي هو حرص ايضا
الصحافه الدوليه والعربيه على الملفات
المطروحه على طاوله الزعماء العرب
من خلال الخلفيه قبل ان نخرج الى الصحف
ولكن نتحدث على داخل المركز الاعلامي خليه
نحل هناك
بالضبط مئات الصحفيين ميسون اتوا من جميع
البلدان العربيه وايضا الدول الدول
الاوروبيه وايضا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وايضا شرق اسيا لتغطيه هذه
القمه الاستثنائيه والتي من المتوقع ان
تساهم بتصفير
المشكلات العربيه وهذا المصطلح استخدمته
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عبر مراسلتها في
الشرق الاوسط في فيفيان ريم في تقرير
نشرته صباح اليوم بان هذه القمه غير عاديه
وحضور الرئيس السوري شخصيا الى جده سيساهم
في عوده سوريا بشكل كبير من خلال مبادرات
وتوصيات ربما يشهدها البيان الختامي للقمه
ايضا صحيفه واشنطن بوست عبر مراسلها في
الشرق الاوسط باسم مروه كتب تقرير ايضا
قبل تقريبا ساعتين اكد فيه على اهميه هذه
القمه وربما عوده سوريا تحل العديد من
الازمات في العراق وفي الاردن وفي
لا سيما اختيار رئيس جمهوريه لبنان
والاتفاق مع فرنسا حول هذا الملف صحيفه
تشرين السوريه ميسون عنونه كالتالي قمه
الامه في جده نعم نستطيع طالما نملك اراده
القرار والفعل وايضا صحيفه الوطن السوريه
تحدثت عن تصريح خاص لوزير الخارجيه السوري
بان سوريا لم تغب اساسا عن القمه العربيه
تم تعليق عضويه سوريا في جامعه الدول
العربيه منذ نوفمبر 2011 ولكن هذه القمه
غير عاديه صحيح كافه المستويات وايضا
بالملفات الساخنه الامن الالماني ايضا
طبعا لاف جدا
بالفعل والتمثيل لافت جدا بس عندي سؤال
فيما يتعلق كونه التمثيل التمثيل على
مستوى عال هل من لقاءات جانبيه حدثت بهذا
اليوم خاصه رئيس المصري الموجود الرئيس
الفلسطيني ايضا وهل هناك من خطط لاجراء
بعض اللقاءات الجانبيه وخاصه ان السعوديه
دوله مستضيفه وبيدها الكثير من الملفات
الملف السوداني
الرئيسي على الطاوله السعوديه ايضا تستضيف
المباحثات بينها الملف الفلسطيني ايضا من
الاولويات تفضل
صحيح ميسون بالاضافه طبعا الى ايضا الحوار
اليمني المنبثق بالاتفاق السعودي اليمني
كان هناك لقاءات جانبيه على مستوى وزراء
الخارجيه وزير الخارجيه السعودي التقى
بنظيرته التونسيه يوم امس عذرا الليبيه
يوم امس ايضا التقى بوزير الخارجيه المصري
متوقعا يحدث هناك محادثات جانبيه بين ولي
العهد السعودي وبعض الزعماء والرؤساء يوم
غد قبيل القمه وايضا ربما نشاهد محادثات
جانبيه او قمم مصغره بعد انعقاد القمه لكن
اغلب اللقاءات الجانبيه هذه ستكون يوم غد
الجمعه ميسون قبيله او بعيده القمه
العربيه التي كما اكدت جميع المؤشرات بان
التمثيل سيكون على على مستوى ربما ثلاثه
او اربعه زعماء عرب فقط لكن الغالبيه
سيكونون حاضرين هنا في جده
للقمه العربيه في جده مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي شكرا جزيلا لك
بدات عضويتها بسبع سنوات في عام 1945
انتهت باثنت 22 دوله عربيه جمعتهم جامعه
الدول العربيه لتحقيق الاهداف المشتركه
ايضا توحيد الصف تجاه مسرح الاحداث
اقليميه
ودوليا دعونا نتعرف على المراحل الاولى
لتاسيس جامعه الدول العربيه قبل حوالي
ثمانيه عقود في هذا التقرير
من الخليج العربي شرقا وحتى المحيط
الاطلسي غربا كانت جامعه الدول العربيه
لنحو ثمانيه عقود حاضره ومظله للدول
العربيه وشعوبها في الازمات فعلى طاولتها
ناقش العرب اصعب قضاياهم الشائكه بر
ئاسه تاريخيا يعود تاسيس جامعه الدول
العربيه الى مارس من العام
1945 لتكون بذلك الاقدم بين المنظمات
العربيه والاقليميه والدوليه منذ نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
فقبيل التاسيس كان العالم يعيش مرحله
حساسه انعكست بطبيعه الحال على المنطقه
فمن ناحيه كانت بوادر نهايه الحرب فرصه
مواتيه لتكاتف الجهود ما اسهم في استقلال
عدد من الدول العربيه ومن ناحيه اخرى
تعززت الحاجه الى الوحده في ظل بروز مخاطر
اقليميه وما صاحب هذه المرحله من احتكاك
متزايد بالغرب ومعاصره تطور النظام الدولي
كلها كانت عوامل محفزه لظهور الجامعه
العربيه التي ولدت فعليا بتوقيع بروتوكول
الاسكندريه عام
1944 حيث كان اساس ميثاق جامعه الدول
العربيه لاحقا والذي وقعته سبع دول هي مصر
وسوريا والسعوديه وشرق الاردن ولبنان
والعراق واليمن ومن الدول السبع اتسعت
الرقعه الجغرافيه لعضويه الجامعه العربيه
لتشمل حتى الان اثنتين وعشرين دوله جمعتها
طاولتها المستديره في الظروف العاديه
والطارئه باهداف مشتركه تصب لتحقيق
المصالح وتوحيد الصف تجاه مسرح الاحداث
اقليميا ودوليا
طبعا اتفاقيات ومعاهدات عده وقعت عليها
الدول الاعضاء في جامعه الدول العربيه من
ابرزها معاهده الدفاع العربي المشترك
والتعاون الاقتصادي التي جاءت لتحقيق
اهداف منها الحفاظ على امن واستقرار الدول
العربيه
[موسيقى]
معاهده الدفاع المشترك والتعاون الاقتصادي
وافق عليها مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه في
13 من ابريل عام
1950 تهدف المعاهده الى تقويه الروابط
وتوثيق التعاون بين الدول العربيه
وضم الصفوف لتحقيق الدفاع المشترك والحفاظ
على امن واستقرار الدول العربيه
ترتب على معاهده الدفاع المشترك والتعاون
الاقتصادي انشاء هيئات منها مجلس الدفاع
المشترك الهيئه الاستشاريه العسكريه
من بنود معاهده الدفاع المشترك والتعاون
الاقتصادي تعتبر الدول المتعاقده كل
اعتداء مسلح يقع على اي دوله او اكثر منها
اعتداء عليها جميعا
[موسيقى]
ميثاق جامعه الدول العربيه حدد اشكال
الاجتماعات التي تعقدها الجامعه سوى على
مستوى القاده او وزراء الخارجيه نتعرف في
هذا التقرير على اليه انعقاد اجتماعاتها
[موسيقى]
القومي العربي وعلى ارض الواقع عقدت
الجامعه العربيه طوال عمرها الذي تجاوز
سبعه وسبعين عاما احدى وثلاثين قمه عاديه
كانت الاولى هي قمه القاهره عام
1964 في موقدت 14 قمه طارئه واربع قمه من
اقتصاديه وعشر قمم عربيه اقليميه
[موسيقى]
الى السودان الان وبعد توقف مستشفى ابو
سعد بمدينه ام درمان عن العمل قامت مجموعه
من المتطوعين من الكوادر الصحيه وافراد
الهلال الاحمر السوداني ولجان المقاومه
بتوفير خدمات صحيه لقطاع اوسع من السكان
في هذه المنطقه بالاضافه طبعا الى المناطق
المجاوره لها كاميرا الحدث زارت المستشفى
ورصدت الاوضاع
كالعديد من المستشفيات التي خرجت عن
الخدمه بسبب الاقتتال والاوضاع الامنيه في
البلاد اوسطت مستشفى ابو سعيد للاطفال
بمدينه ام درمان ابوابها امام المرضى بسبب
نقص الكوادر ونفاذ المستلزمات الطبيه
اطباء ومتطوعون من الهلال الاحمر والجان
المقاومه بالمنطقه بادروا شخصيا الى اعاده
فتح المستشفى واستقبال المرضى وتعمل
المستشفى الى جانب تخصصها في الاطفال على
استقبال الحالات الطارئه خاصه وان منطقه
ابو سعيد تقع وسط مواجهات طرفي النزاع ومع
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي يبادر المتطوعون
ايضا الى امداد المستشفى بالمياه بعد
جلبها من النيل الابيض المجاور للمنطقه
بالاضافه الى جمع التبرعات لشراء وقود
السوق السوداء لتشغيل مولده المستشفى
لاجئين بشرق دارفور غربي السودان خاصه
توقف جميع المنظمات العامله في الحقل
الانسان التي يعتمد عليها سكان المعسكرات
وذلك في كافه الخدمات
هذا هو معسكر كريو للاجئين القادمين من
جنوب السودان يقعوا المعسكر في ولايه شرق
دارفور محليه بحر العرب الحدوديه مع ولايه
بحر الغزال بجنوب السودان تضم عسكرات
اللاجئين المتواجدين في شرق دارفور اكثر
من 200 الف لاجئ موزعين في محليات مختلفه
بولايه شرق دارفور خروج المنظمات المفاجئ
اثره كثيرا على واقع المعسكرات هنا بشرق
دارفور خاصه فيما يتعلق بخدمات المياه
هنالك منظمات كانت تقوم بتشغيل محطات
كثيره
بمعسكرات اللجوء بشرق دارفور كانت تجلب
الوقود وايضا تقوم بعمليات صيانه هذه
المحطات هذه الاعمال توقفت في الايام التي
شهدت قتال بين الجيش والدعم السريع مغادره
منظمات تعمل في هذا الحقل لابد انه نحتاج
الى مساعده المنظمات خاصه في توفير الوقود
لتشغيل مضخات المياه من هذا المعسكر نرسل
النداء الى المنظمه الانسانيه التي كانت
تعمل معنا لتوفير الوقود لان الماء هو
شريان الحياه بالاضافه لمعاناه المياه
هنالك ايضا شح واضح في الخدمات الصحيه
هنالك منظمات كانت تقوم بتشغيل مستشفيات
داخل معسكرات اللجوء اليوم توقفت هذه
المستشفيات خاصه بعد دمار عدد كبير من
مخازن الدواء باقليم دارفور في جنوب
دارفور
للخريف نحن على ابواب فصل الخريف حيث
يتوالد البعوض والذباب وتنتشر الامراض
تبعا لذلك لا تتوفر حاليا ادويه في
المعسكر وزاره الصحه بولايه شرق دارفور
كانت ترسل لنا الادويه عبر الجنينه
والفاشر وانيال ولكن بسبب الاوضاع الحاليه
فلن تستطيع ارسال الادويه
وصل عدد سكان المعسكر في شرق دارفور الى
اكثر من 250 الف شخص وهذا عدد كبير نناشد
الحكومه بارسال نداء الى المنظمات لاننا
نحتاج الى الماء والدواء والغذاء وبحسب
مسؤولين داخل المعسكر ما زالت عمليات
الوصول الى معسكر كريو مستمره من ولايه
الخرطوم ومن ولايه اخرى في اقليم دارفور
الولايات التي شهدت اضطرابات ومعارك خلال
الايام الماضيه الامر الذي يحتاج الى تدخل
عاجل من المنظمات لانغاز الموقف
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا دعونا نعود اليوم الى عام 1963
تحديدا مع اغتيال الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق
جي اف كندي بطلقه ناريه في وضح النهار
طبعا في مدينه دالاس منذ ذلك الحين بقيت
جريمه اغتيال الرئيس الامريكي لغز لم تكشف
ابعاده حتى هذه اللحظه طبعا مع اقتراب
موعد الانتخابات الامريكيه عادت القضيه
غير المكتمله الى الظهور فلربما يكون لدى
ترامب هذه المره الاجابات للتفاصيل
الناقصه في مقابله خاصه مع صحيفه ماسنجر
صرح الرئيس الامريكي السابق بانه سيكشف عن
جميع الوثائق السريه المتعلقه بقضيه كندي
الوثائق كان قد تم حجبها عمدا عن الشعب
الامريكي من اجل حمايه الامن القومي
وانفاذ القانون طبعا بحسب خبراء لكن وعد
ترامب هذا طبعا جاء بشرط هذا الوعد باي
يعاد انتخابه للرئاسه الامريكيه مجددا
روبرت كندي نجل شقيق جون الكندي ومرشح اخر
في سباق الانتخابات الامريكيه ادلى الشهر
الماضي بتصريحات صادمه اتهم فيها
المخابرات الامريكيه باغتيال عمه تصريحات
تعد تحديا واضحا للروايه الرسميه للحكومه
الامريكيه عن مطلق النار الوحيد لهارفي
اوزبالد والذي يزعم انه كان عميلا للاتحاد
السوفيتي في عام 1992 كان الرئيس انداك
جورج بوش الاب والذي كان يشغل منصب مدير
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه وقد وقع قانونا
يفرض الكشف العالمي عن جميع الوثائق
المتعلقه بجون كندي مع ذلك امتنعت
الادارات المتعاقبه بما في ذلك اداره
الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن عن الكشف عن مضمون
هذه الوثائق
افادت وسائل اعلام روسيه ان خطا للسكك
الحديديه في جزيره القرم قد تعرض لاستهداف
ادى الى وقف حركه القطارات هذا يحدث في
وقت دوره انفجارات عده فجر الخميس في كييف
ومناطق اوكرانيا اخرى حيث ناشدت السلطات
السكان لاحتماء في الملاجئ حسبما اعلنت
الاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيه وقال وهو رئيس الاداره المدنيه
والعسكريه في كييف قال انه تم تسجيل سقوط
حطام في منطقه دارنتسكي في العاصمه ويجري
التحقق من البيانات الخاصه بالضحايا
والاضرار
هذا وقالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان
روسيا تمنع مسؤولين كبار من الاستقاله على
الارجح وذلك تزامنا مع استمرار الحرب في
اوكرانيا الدفاع البريطانيه في تقرير لها
اضافه ان المنع يشمل على الاقل قاده
المناطق ومسؤوليه الامن والرئاسه كما
اوضحت انه من المرجح ان يكون العديد من
المسؤولين متشككين للغايه في الحرب مشيره
الى ان منعهم ياتي عبر تلميحات لهم بانهم
قد يواجهون اتهامات جنائيه ملفقه في حال
استقالتهم
اعلن سكرتير مجلس الامن البيلاروسي
الكسندر فولفوفيتش عن وجود محاولات لادخال
اسلحه وايضا متفجرات الى البلاد عبر
الحدود مع اوكرانيا وتنفيذ اعمال تخريبيه
مشيرا الى ان تقارير افادت بوجود مخططات
لتنفيذ اعمال تخريبيه وايضا عمليات اخرى
لا تخدم المصالح الدوليه مدفع بالسلطات في
بيلاروسيا الى انشاء نظام استجابه للرد
على الاعمال الارهابيه وانشطه الجماعات
المسلحه غير الشرعيه كانت النتائج ايجابيه
افاد مراسل العربيه باقتحام 400 مستوطن
اسرائيلي لباحات المسجد الاقصى صباح اليوم
بحمايه مشدده من الشرطه الاسرائيليه يحدث
هذا فيما يسود التوتر في القدس وجوارها
استعدادا لمسيره الاعلام التي تنظمها
جماعات يمنيه متطرفه الشرطه الاسرائيليه
نشرت اكثر من 3000 فرد من قواتها في القدس
لتامين المسيره
هذا وقت حمى قوات اسرائيليه ايضا مدينه
نابلس في الضفه الغربيه فجر اليوم اشتبكت
مع فلسطينيين ما اسفر عن اصابه العشرات
بجروح وقد نقلت وكاله معا للانباء عن احمد
جبريل وهو المتحدث باسم الهلال الاحمر في
نابلس استخدام الجيش الاسرائيلي للرصاص
المعدني المغلف بالمطاط واظهرت صور على
الانترنت اطلاق الجيش الغاز المسيل للدموع
في حواره البلده القديمه
[موسيقى]
اطلقت منظمه حقوقيه مقرها بريطانيا خارطه
تفاعليه توثق انتهاكات حقوق الانسان منذ
استيلاء طالبان على افغانستان طبعا
المنظمه تهدف عبر ما اسمته بخارطه الشهود
الى لفت الانتباه الى تصاعد الانتهاكات ضد
المدنيين والصحفيين والاقليات العرقيه في
جميع انحاء البلاد حيث كشفت المنظمه في
الخارطه عن اكثر من
1300 نقطه بيانات للحوادث والانتهاكات منذ
سابع عشر من اغسطس 2021
واستخدمت فيها بيانات ومعلومات مفتوحه
المصدر للتحقيق في انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
وجرائم الحرب
فاطمه عظيم احدى الطبيبات اللواتي تم
توظيفهن حديثا في اكبر مستشفى لصحه الطفل
في البلاد لا يمكن تشغيل قسم الصحه بدون
مشاركه السيدات كما تقول فاطمه
[موسيقى]
الصحه الافغانيه تعترف بمضى حاجه قطاع
الصحه والعلاج لمشاركه السيدات اذ تشكل
الشريحه الضعيفه من النساء والاطفال اكثر
من نصف المجتمع الافغاني العربيه
خطط فرنسا خطوه كبيره في اتجاه زياده
القدرات القتاليه للجيش الاوكراني فبعد 24
ساعه على استقباله الرئيس فلاديمير
زيلنسكي اعلن ايمانويل ماكرون عن ان بلاده
ستزود اوكرانيا بصواريخ من جهه اخرى اعلنت
المانيا استعدادها لتسليم اوكرانيا اكبر
حزمه عسكريه منذ بدايه الحرب التفاصيل مع
الزميلين حسين قنيبر من باريس وراغده
بهنام من برلين
هنا في باريس التي زار هذا ليسكي بعد روما
وبرلين وقبل لندن كان ابرز ما قاله ماكرون
امام ضيفه ان فرنسا سترسل المزيد من
الصواريخ الى اوكرانيا لكن الاهم من ذلك
قول الرئيس الفرنسي ان مدى هذه الصواريخ
سيكون ابعد من مدى تلك التي ارسلتها باريس
سابقا الى ما سيمكن هذه الاخيره بحسب
الرئيس الفرنسي من الشروع في شن هجومها
المضاد على الجيش الروسي فرنسا ستقوم ايضا
بتاهيل طيارين عسكريين اوكرانيين وهنا
يرفض الاليزي التعليق حول امكانيه الربط
بين هذه الخطوه واحتمال ارسال باريس يوما
ما طائرات مقاتله الى كييف وسيرسل
الفرنسيون ايضا المزيد من المركبات
المدرعه والدبابات الخفيفه ومنظومات
الدفاع الجوي تقول باريس ان هدف تكثيف
دعمها لاوكرانيا عسكريا دفاعي لا هجومي
عندما دخلت روسيا الى اوكرانيا خرقت ميثاق
الامم المتحده الاوكرانيون يدافعون عن
انفسهم ولذلك تعطيهم فرنسا السلاح روسيا
بلد يعتدي في كل الاتجاهات لا يمكن اجراء
حوار مع بوت الذي يسعى الى اجتياح الدول
المجاوره ووضعها تحت سيطرته الدعم الفرنسي
لاوكرانيا ياتي في سياق دعم اوروبي واسع
النطاق تقول باريس انه قد يعدل موازين
القوى العسكري لصالح كياف هنا استقبل
المستشار الالماني قبل بضعه ايام الرئيس
الاوكراني
بحضوره عن اكبر حزمه مساعدات عسكريه
تقدمها برلين لكياف منذ بدايه الحرب بقيمه
ثلاثه مليارات دولار امريكي لتصبح المانيا
بذلك ثاني اكبر مانع عسكري لاوكرانيا بعد
الولايات المتحده حزمه المساعدات
الالمانيه الجديده تضم 30 دبابه ليوبارت
كانت ترددت المانيا بالموافقه على تسليمها
لكياف ما تسبب بتوتر العلاقه بين الطرفين
الحزمه الضخمه الجديده تطم ايضا 20 ناقله
جنود مدرعه من نوع اضافه الى اربعه انظمه
ايروس المتطوره المضاده للطائرات
المساعدات التي قدمت الى الجانب الاوكراني
هي مساعدات للدفاع والاستعاده على الاراضي
الروسيه التي الاوكرانيه التي تم
استحلالها احتلالا من قبل الجانب الروسي
بمعنى اخر
لم يتم اعطاء او لم يتم الموافقه على
اعطاء طائرات هجوميه او صواريخ هجوميه حتى
ان تلك الانظمه الصاروخيه التي اعطيت الى
الجانب الاوكراني لا يتعدى مداها ال 120
كيلومتر اسلحه المانيه جديده يامل الرئيس
الاوكراني ان تساعد على بدء الهجوم المؤجل
لدفع القوات الروسيه على الانسحاب
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا عوده الى القمه العربيه نتابع
معا هذه الصور من جده وصلتنا قبل قليل
طبعا لوصول العاهل البحريني الى جده لتراس
وفد بلاده في القمه العربيه الثانيه
والثلاثين اذا وصول ملك البحرين حمد بن
عيسى ال خليفه الى جده
طبعا ياتي وصول العاهل البحرين بعد ان كان
هناك اعلان عن وصول الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس ايضا الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي كان من اوائل من وصلوا الى جده
لحضور هذه القمه ننتظر ايضا وصول الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد كان الاعلان عن وصوله
حوالي الساعه السابعه ولحمه عربيه جديده
تجمع الدول العربيه كامله اضافه الى اعلان
عن مشاركه الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني امير
دوله قطر ايضا في هذه القمه
اذا هذه الصور وصلتنا قبل قليل لوصول
العهل البحريني حمد بن عيسى الخليفه الى
جده للمشاركه في القمه العربيه التي تبدا
غدا الوفود
والقيادات تصل تباعا كما لاحظنا حتى صباح
الغد ومن ثم غدا ستنطلق هذه القمه وهناك
اجماع بين كل الدول المشاركه العربيه
لعوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه
واتخاذ مقعدها مجددا بعد غياب لسنوات
وبالتالي ستكون هناك مشاركه مباشره من
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
خلص تقرير لجنه برلمانيه بان البرلمان
البريطاني بحاجه ماسه الى اصلاح وايضا
ترميم والا سيواجه خطرا انهيار حقيقي بسبب
بطء عمليه الترميم دعت اللجنه بعد سنوات
من مماطله النواب الى وضع خطه واضحه
التكلفه والجدول الزمني لانجاز المهمه قبل
فوات الاوان
مبنى البرلمان هذا على ضفافه نهر التايمز
والمطل على ساعه بيجبان من المعالم
التاريخيه الشهيره في العالم وواجهه
سياحيه لملايين السياح من كل مكان لكن هذا
الصرح مهدد بالانهيار
[موسيقى]
فتقرير للجنه المحاسبه العامه بمجلس
العموم التي تدقق في مصاريف البرلمان خلص
بان خطه الترميم المبنى الواجب اعتمادها
بطيئه في التعامل مع احداث من تسرب المطر
من السقف وسقوط قطع من البناء الى الجدران
الملوث بماده
بصحه العاملين بداخله والحرائق المتفرقه
هذا بشهادات مسؤولين على ترميم وتجديد
البرلمان المعروف بقصر وسميستر في
افاداتهم امام اللجنه البرلمانيه المعنيه
امن ولكنهم متداعن في مناطق رئيسيه معينه
وبحاجه ماسه الى الترميم ومن اجل الحفاظ
على سلامته على سبيل المثال من خطر نشوب
حريق كارثي يتعين علينا القيام بدوريات
عديده حيث ليس لدينا نظام قوي لمن عندلاع
الحرائق وانتشارها
لجنه المحاسبه تلوم سنوات من المماطله بعد
تحديد مجلس النواب قبل خمس سنوات لمسار
العمل الذي يكلف مليوني جنيه استرليني في
الاسبوع على مدى سبعه اعوام وخاصه النواب
الذين يرفضون الانتقال الى مباني اخرى ما
سيرفع التكلفه الترميم وصيانه المبنى الى
اكثر من 20 مليارا ويستغرق عشرات السنين
اذا استمرت الجلسه الصاخبه في البرلمان
اثناء عمليه الترميم
برلمان بريطانيا ام البرلمانات في العالم
وواجهه البلاد في الخارج بنيته التحتيه
تتاكل وقد يتعرض للتدمير قبل اصلاحه ما لم
يتوقف المسؤولون والنواب عن تجاوز
المسؤوليه بشان مخاوف التكاليف الباهظه
لعمليه الترميم في زمن التقشف مصطفى زاروه
العربيه لندن
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
تتابعنا تغطيه خاصه للقمه العربيه الثانيه
32 من استديوهاتنا في جده
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ومباشره الى
منتهى والتغطيه المباشره للقمه العربيه من
استوديو العربيه في جده منتهى تفضلي
شكرا عزيزتي ميسون وشكرا يا ميسون واهلا
بكم معنا مشاهدينا الكرام نتابع معكم هذه
التغطيه من هنا من جده حيث انعقاد القمه
العربيه الثانيه 32 والتي تشهد تحديات
عديده جديده منها هذه الازمه في السودان
والحرب الاوكرانيه باضافه الى ما تشهده
هذه القمه من اختراق بعوده سوريا الى
اجتماعات القمه التي دام انقطاعها عنها
اثني عشر عاما اهلا بكم
عوده سوريا
عوده في سياق
ساعه عربي لتسهيل تسويه الوضع السوري سميه
الوضع السوري زميل اشكاليه السوريه
والحكومه السوريه والحكم في سوريا قابل
بان تكون هذه العوده في سياق بحث في كيفيه
وبالتالي في كيفيه
الازمه وبالتالي
العرب طرحوا نفسهم
اساسا
لمساعد للحكومه السوريه
للتواصل الى بر الامان او البر الاستقرار
او
للحديث عن هذه القمه وما حولها وما هو
متوقع منها
والبيان الختامي يسعدنا ان نرحب في
استوديو العربيه بالدكتور سميح المعايطه
وزير الاعلام الاردني الاسبق الهم بكم
الان لو اردنا ان نعطي عنوانا لهذه القمه
ماذا نقول
يعني قمه ايجابيه كانت
لولا الازمه السودانيه يعني الاجواء اللي
عليها قمه السعوديه كانت هي اجواء ايجابيه
جدا فيها حاله من خلينا نقول غياب التوتر
في الحالة العربيه كان
ما فيش قضايا خلافيه كثير من او كبرى بين
الوفود الحاضره حتى الناس اللي كانوا
الدول المعارضه لعوده سوريا للجامعه
العربيه يتعاملوا بهدوء شديد احتفظوا
بموقفهم فيما يتعلق بعلاقتهم الثنائيه مع
سوريا لكنهم احترموا القرار العام اللي
موجود للجامعه العربيه القمه فيها هذه
الاجواء فيها اجواء تجوز بعض الناس ترجع
سوريا للجامعه العربيه زي الناس خصوم حكم
بسوريا لكن في نهايه المطاف هذه حاله
عربيه كان ممكن تكون هي يعني فيها اجواء
ايجابي وبعتقد السبب الاساسي اذا بدك تحكي
عن اللي خلى التحولات تمشي سريعا هو
التحولات مش التحولات خلي المسارات
السياسيه للدوله السعوديه السعوديه باخر
سنه من شهر سته الماضي تتذكري زياره بايدن
لهون قبل سنه والقمه اللي كانت والنتائجها
وتفاصيلها اللي كانت بعدين القمه الصينيه
العربيه والخليجيه والسعوديه وراحت
السعوديه اتجاه الصين في ظل يعني ازمه
عالميه ازمه حرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
وبعدين تفاهمها مع ايران اتفاق المهم جدا
اللي كمان السعوديه اعطت زي ما بيسووا
كريدت للصين تستضيف وهي تقود وترعل
التفاهم بعدين عوده العلاقات مع الايران
والدخول في تفاصيل خلينا نقول الامور
الطبيعيه بالعلاقات بما فيها الازمات
للسعوديه جدا كمنطقه بعدين تحول الذهاب
سعوديه نحو عوده مع سوريا تبنيها فكره
عوده مع سوريا وتبنيها المبادره الاردنيه
اللي هي من سنتين بموضوع اللي هي العربي
ان يقود العرب مبادره لحل الازمه السوريه
مع العالم تحت نظام خطوه بخطوه لحل الازمه
فكانت هذه التحولات الموقف السعودي او
السياسه السعوديه باخر سنه بعتقد هي صنعت
هذه الاجواء اللي خلت هذه القمه مختلفه عن
القمم بالفترات الماضيه
بتعرف برغم تعقيداته ورغم التطرف اللي
بتتعامل فيه الحكومه الاسرائيليه لو رغم
خروجنا من عدوان على غزه اسرائيلي لكن ملف
في رتابه صار العربيه للاسف ورتابه
بتفاصيله والموقف العربي رح يكون في موقف
المعتاد التاكيد على حل الدولتين وتاكيد
على عمليه السلام
سميح بس بس على القضيه الفلسطينيه اذا
سمحت لي يعني كل ما كان في هناك فرقه
عربيه في احوال عربيه غير مستقره داخل
الدول العربيه في معاناه داخل الدول
العربيه ستتراجع القضيه الفلسطينيه في
الاولويه لصالح قضايا اخرى داخليه
واقليميه الان هل حالتها وهذه الرؤيه رؤيه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه نحو حلحله هذه
المشاكل والالتفات لموضوع التنميه
والاستقرار والتقدم في المنطقه كمان ممكن
يساعد القضيه الفلسطينيه بس اليوم المشكله
باسرائيل اكثر من انه زمان كانوا العرب
كانوا عندهم رافضين للعمليه السياسيه ما
بدهم سلام مع اسرائيل اليوم الحاله
العربيه تتقبل اقامه حتى السعوديه بتعلن
انها مستعده لمفاوضات مع اسرائيل لكن بشرط
حل القضيه الفلسطينيه وفق القرارات الدولي
المشكله اليوم انه اسرائيل كمجتمع ومؤسسات
بتروح لليمين ولابعد لما بعد اليمين ولذلك
موقف الاسرائيلي هو اللي صار معيق يعني
احنا انا بتذكر اليوم بقمه بيروت وكنا
صحفيين بالقمه في ذلك الوقت بالالفين كان
الموقف العربي مبادر العربيه اللي هي كانت
مبادره الامير الملك عبد الله بن عبد
العزيز رحمه الله كانت مبادره بس كانت
خطوه كانوا الاسرائيليين يعني الناس يتوقع
لكن الموقف كان حصار لعرفات والاسرائيليين
رفضوا فاليوم المشكله مش بالعرب ما بعتقد
اليوم في علاقات عربيه واسرائيليه اكثر من
طرف في معاهدات مع اكثر من طرب وفي موقف
ايجابي من الدول المهمه نحو عمليه السلام
بس اسرائيل اليوم هي اللي بتتعامل بفوقيه
مع القصه الفلسطينيه وتحت قناعات انها
ليست مضطره لاعطاء الفلسطينيين اي الحقوق
لانه ما في شيء ضاغط عليها فهذا الموضوع
اليوم المشكله بدنا نعالج المشكله
الاسرائيليه
والذهاب اللي موجود يعني احنا بنشوف اليوم
مسيره الاعلام بالقدس يعني من السياسات
الاسرائيليه المستفزه للعرب وللست بشكل
كبير فعشان هيك بتظل القضيه الفلسطينيه
مدام المفتاح الاساسي انه الامريكان
بيحكوا كلام كويس عن فلسطين وحل الدولتين
لكن ما اخذوا ولا خطوه عمليه
نتجاوز شيء مهم جدا وانا ما بدخل لكل
الحوار عن القضيه الفلسطينيه بس عم يتجاوز
شيء مهم جدا فيما يتعلق بالقضيه
الفلسطينيه
وانا ذكرت بالامس انه الصراع الفلسطيني
الاسرائيلي معروف احنا الان امام ازمه
اكبر هي صراع الفلسطيني الفلسطيني انقسام
الفلسطيني الفلسطيني على الاقل لو لم يكن
هناك قدره
او هناك موقف من قبل دول العالم لحل حاله
هذه المساله العالم الغربي فيمكن الدول
العربيه تكون قادره على يعني
تقريبًا بتحكي عن حضرتك اليوم شوفي
اسرائيل وين نجحت بال 17 سنه الاخيره من
بعد الانقسام الفلسطيني اليوم بصير عدوان
على غزه بصير عدوان على فصيل بغزه وصحيل
الثاني بتضامن معه فصيلين يعني مش انه
لسه بنحكي غزه حماس وجهاد بنحكي غزه لما
بصير عدوان بالضفه غزه بتضامن بتصير يعني
الحاله بتخدم اسرائيل هسه بنحكي بالنوايا
انه والله هدول ناويين بس انت عمليا سلوكك
بخدم الاسرائيليه
انه انا ما في داعي اتنازل يعني بين نازل
اعطي للفلسطيني اي حق من حقوقه ليش يعني
ما تحت ضغط ولا في حاله فلسطينيه مشجعه
ولا حاله دوليه بالاخر بستخدموه دائما ما
في شريك للسلام اذا كنا بدنا نعمل عمليه
اليوم
اللي ارتاحوا له ايام ترامب صفقه القرن بس
ما مشيت الامور جزئيا في بعض المسائل في
جانب مهم جدا في القمه وتم نقاشه الحقيقه
على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه العرب وفي
الاجتماعات الثنائيه المجتمعات الاجتماعات
اللي صارت بعمان واللي صارت به اكثر من
مكان ببغداد وغيرها وهي الملف الاقتصادي
تتصور انه ممكن يكون الملف الاقتصادي هو
المدخل نحو حلحله كل المشكلات على المستوى
يعني العالم العربي يعني بيكون هو المفتاح
اللي لم الشمل العربي ممكن
هو صحيح بس هو بيعمل في نظريه بالعرب
بالاخر سنتين ثلاث انشغلت بين الدول
الاطار الاردني العراقي المصري الاطار
الاماراتي الاردني المصري البحريني هاي
القطن صار في وجهه نظر اخرى انه تعالوا
نحكي بقضايا التنميه والاقتصاد خاصه بعد
كورونا يعني يحيدوا من القصص سياسيه وانت
وبعدين مش على قاعده انه بلد يقدم مساعدات
للبلد انه خلينا نستثمر مع بعض مثل ملف
الادويه لانه كورونا ببين قديش في هذا
الملف ضاغط ومهم بالعالم تعالوا نحكي بملف
الامن الغذائي القمح والصناعات الغذائيه
هذا الوجهه النظر الميدانيه الواقعيه كثير
بعتقد هذه اذا توسعت عن طريق القمه
لاطر اقتصاديه مو زمان زمان كنا نحكي عن
التكامل العربي الاقتصاد العربي يعني كان
في حاله شعارات كبيره وبالاخر نكتشف انه
اتفاقيات الجمركيه بين بعض الدول معيقه
لاي شيء اليوم هذا التفكير اللي كان
بالقطر السابقه لو يتوسع الناس تحكي تعال
انا شو بخدمك وتعال شو بتخدمني يعني بلاش
مش على اي قاعده صحيح العروبه يعني هذا
مبدا مهم والقذا بس تعال انت شو عندك
تعال نتعاون نخدم بعض هذا المنطق بعتقد
لازم يدخل على الفكر العربي الجماعي ويصير
هو اللي بيحكم لانه بيوصلنا للنتائج اما
نحكي بالقضايا العامه والهذا بنضل نحكي
فيها بدون كل القضايا العامه بحاجه الى
فكفكه يعني اجزاء اللي هو المصلحه نجح
بالامور الجزئيه لا يعني راح نتابع دكتور
سميح اليوم وغدا لقراءه
هامش هذه القمه وما يمكن ان ينتج عنها
شكرا جزيلا لك
على التواجد معنا واعود مره اخرى
لزملائي في دبي لميسون عزام اليكم شكرا
عزيزتي منتهى
العضويه في جامعه الدول العربيه بدات بسبع
دول حين تاسست واتسعت لاحقا على مر
السنوات لتشمل اثنتين وعشرين دوله
تنقسم العضويه في جامعه الدول العربيه الى
نوعين هما عضويه اصليه وعضويه بالانضمام
العضويه الاصليه هي مثبته للدول المستقله
السبعه التي وقعت على ميثاق جامعه الدول
العربيه
اما العضويه بالانضمام فهي تشمل بقيه
الدول المنضمه لاحقا
ويؤكد ميثاق الجامعه على حق كل دوله عربيه
مستقله في الانضمام اليها بعد تقديم طلب
وموافقه الاعضاء بالاجماع
ميثاق الجامعه يتيح ايضا للدول الاعضاء
الانسحاب من العضويه اضافه الى فصل او طرد
دوله بالاجماع
علقت الجامعه العربيه عضويه ثلاث دول هي
مصر وسوريا وليبيا قبل ان تعيد عضويه هذه
الدول في اوقات لاحقه اخرها سوريا في
السابع من مايو الحالي
[موسيقى]
اعلن البيت الابيض في بيان ان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيس الوزراء الياباني
ناقشا عدد من الملفات المهمه وسبل تعزيز
التعاون الدفاعي ومواجهه السلوك القصري
للصين ياتي الاجتماع الثنائي بعد وصول
الرئيس بايدن الى اليابان لحضور قمه
مجموعه السبع
افاد مراسل العربيه بان حاكمه فلوريدا
سيعلن ترشحه رسميا للانتخابات الرئاسه
الاسبوع المقبل وكان الحاكم قد بدا في
اولى خطواته الرسميه لاطلاق حملته
الانتخابيه الرسميه باستدعائه كبار
الداعمين الماليين الى ميامي الاسبوع
القادم
انتهت المرحله الحاسمه في عمليه فصل
التوام السيامي النيجيري حسانه وحسينا
بقياده الدكتور عبد الله الربيعه و 35
مستشار من الكوادر الطبيه في مستشفى الملك
عبد الله التخصصي للاطفال في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض كان الدكتور عبد الله
الربيعه قد اوضح ان العمليه الجراحيه
للتوام النيجيري من المتوقع ان تجرى على
ثماني مراحل وتستغرق حوالي اربعه عشره
ساعه مضيفا في الوقت ذاته ان التوام
السيامي تشتركان في البطن والحوض والكبد
والامعاء والجهاز البولي والتناسلي وعظام
الحوض
الخامس انتهت شكرا للمتابعه مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات